Will Captain Pike's first officer be sent
to prison? Have we really seen the last of
Chief Engineer Hemmer? And when will James
T. Kirk show up again? These are just some
of the questions left unanswered at the end
of Season 1 of Star Trek: Strange New Worlds.
Captain Pike's tough-as-nails first officer
Number One holds near-legendary status in Star
Trek history. Previously only seen in the original
series episode "The Menagerie," which used clips
from the unaired original pilot episode, fans
have always been fascinated by the character.
Strange New Worlds finally reveals
Number One's real name, Una Chin-Riley,
and gives us her backstory as a
genetically modified Illyrian.
In the episode Ghosts of Illyria it's
said that because of the Federation's
ban on genetic tampering, people like Number
One are barred from serving in Starfleet.
As such, her Illyrian heritage has
been kept a closely guarded secret.
When Captain Pike learns her true nature,
he vows to never reveal it because she is
the finest first officer in the fleet.
Yet, somehow, the information gets out.
In the season finale, Pike's colleague
and lover Captain Batel beams aboard the
Enterprise with a security detail and arrests
Number One for the crime of being an Illyrian.
We're curious about what will happen now, and
who leaked the information to Starfleet. The fact
that franchise canon has never mentioned her could
suggest she spends the rest of her days in prison.
Either way, it would seem that Number One's fate
will be a major story heading into Season 2.
Hard-nosed Enterprise security chief La'An
Noonien-Singh's last name hints at a frightening
lineage. In Ghosts of Illyria, we learn that
one of her ancestors is none other than Ricardo
Montalbán's villainous Khan. But it was La'An's
tragic backstory that added pathos to the series.
In Memento Mori we learn La'An
was rescued as a child by Number
One from a Gorn breeding planet
after the Gorn killed her family.
La'An uses her experience with the Gorn to
defeat a swarm of Gorn ships in the episode.
Then in All Those Who Wander she gets a
measure of revenge by killing three Gorn
hatchlings and rescuing a young girl.
Perhaps reminded of her own ordeal,
La'An takes a leave of absence to help the
child locate her family. But will she return?
We know actor Christina Chong will be back for
Season 2. But will we follow her quest to reunite
the girl with her family or see her return to a
different Starfleet ship? Chong has revealed to
Cinema Blend that she has filmed scenes with
James T. Kirk actor Paul Wesley, stating:
"I can't speak on story, but I can
say that Paul Wesley is very funny,
and I love working with him."
The alternate future Pike glimpsed in the season
finale does show La'An serving as a commander
aboard Kirk's ship. This may suggest La'An
eventually finds a home on the U.S.S. Farragut.
The cast of Star Trek: Strange New Worlds
Season 1 combined old favorites like
Captain Pike and Mr. Spock with exciting new
characters like chief engineer Lt. Hemmer.
The series' most distinct alien officer
and biggest breakout character, Hemmer is
an Aenar — an offshoot of the Andorians — who
possesses a form of precognition and telepathy.
By the end of the first season, however,
Hemmer sacrifices himself to save the
rest of his shipmates. His death leaves
the ship without a chief engineer. Is it
possible that Chief Engineer Montgomery
Scott will make his debut next season?
Or are we due for another new character
to work miracles in the engine room?
"I like this ship! You know, it's exciting!"
Actor Bruce Horak, who plays Hemmer, has said he's
not done with the series in several interviews.
Whether this means Hemmer's telepathy
allowed his consciousness to survive like
Spock's in Star Trek III or that
he will somehow be resurrected,
perhaps the next chief
engineer will still be Hemmer.
Though fans were excited to see Pike,
Spock, and Number One in Strange New Worlds,
anticipation reached another level when Paramount
announced that James T. Kirk would be in Season 2.
According to canon, Pike and Kirk met
only briefly. The Strange New Worlds
Season 1 finale snuck actor Paul Wesley
into the role for a "what if" story that
took place in the future, but Kirk's
role for Season 2 remains a mystery.
We know Kirk is currently a young
lieutenant serving aboard the U.S.S.
Farragut. One possibility is that
Season 2 may involve dual stories
set aboard the Enterprise and Farragut,
with Kirk receiving a recurring role.
Based on the original Star Trek we know
Kirk and Spock knew each other for years,
so it's likely Spock will get some serious
screen time with his future Enterprise captain.
However it shakes out, Wesley impressed
as Kirk in his appearance in A Quality of
Mercy. Unless Paramount's announcement
was a ruse to hide the finale's plot,
we should get plenty more of him next season.
Since Strange New Worlds is set
nearly a decade before Star Trek:
The Original Series, it was
definitely unexpected to see actor
Celia Rose Gooding playing Cadet Nyota
Uhura on the bridge of the Enterprise.
Throughout Season 1, Uhura evolved
from a fresh-faced cadet to a strong,
capable officer-in-training, growing close to
chief engineer Hemmer while rotating
through every division on the ship.
But Uhura's dilemma persisted — does
she really want to serve in Starfleet?
Uhura makes it clear she may not want to
remain on the Enterprise, unsure if this
is the right path for her. But thanks to
her friendship with engineer Hemmer — and,
ultimately, his sacrifice — it seems
Uhura may have finally decided to stay.
However, will she be awarded a full rank of
ensign, an "acting ensign" provisional title,
or could she return to Starfleet Academy?
We do know she'll be back on the Enterprise
by the time Kirk takes command, but what
happens in the meantime is anyone's guess.
Sonequa Martin-Green's Michael Burnham wasn't
the first lost Spock sibling to be retconned
into the franchise. Way back in 1989, the fifth
Star Trek feature film introduced us to Sybok,
the illegitimate son of Spock's father Sarek. He's
a Vulcan who rejected logic and became a fanatic
devoted to finding God at the center
of the galaxy. The film was met with
plenty of jeers and no subsequent Star Trek
series or film dared to mention Sybok again.
"No! No! It's not possible!"
All that changed in Strange New Worlds when the
episode The Serene Squall revealed Sybok is being
held in the Vulcan rehabilitation facility
where Spock's betrothed T'Pring serves.
Spock notes that he has been told to avoid
contact with his half-brother at all costs,
and the ominous reveal seems to imply
that the villainous Vulcan may yet return.
It has even been rumored among fans that Sybok
could become the behind-the-scenes villain of
Season 2. The fact that the episode never shows
his face seems like a strange creative choice if
he wasn't set to return in some fashion. This way,
any actor could step into the role, and with Sam
Witwer campaigning for the part on Twitter,
another appearance could be on the horizon.
Pulled from a pair of appearances on the original
Star Trek series, Strange New Worlds made minor
character Dr. M'Benga a series regular,
and the Enterprise's chief medical officer.
Expanding on the little-explored role, we
learn his first name is Joseph and that
he has a daughter named Rukiya who is suffering
from a terminal disease. M'Benga's relationship
with his daughter provides some of the most
touching and heartfelt moments in Season 1.
Strangely, in his two appearances from the 1960s,
Dr. M'Benga actually serves under Dr. McCoy,
who is in charge of sickbay when
Kirk commands the Enterprise.
What happens to M'Benga to bump him from the
commanding doctor aboard the flagship of the
Federation to a supporting surgeon? We know
M'Benga risked the lives of the Enterprise
crew in Ghosts of Illyria by not revealing that
his daughter was being held in the transporter.
Could this have been a violation
of regulations that gets M'Benga
demoted? Or is there another incident
lined up for a future episode that sees
M'Benga either forcibly removed from
his role or voluntarily stepping down?
With Season 2 already filmed, we may
not have to wait long to find out,
though there's nothing to say that the
change in rank takes place anytime soon.
In the 1990s, Star Trek was one of the first
franchises that had multiple projects side
by side, with both movies and TV shows running
together. Still, while a few characters moved
back and forth, few proper crossovers actually
materialized. With Marvel, DC, and others pushing
interconnected franchises, could Strange New
Worlds finally see a major Star Trek crossover?
When asked about future crossovers, franchise
overlord Alex Kurtzman told Deadline Podcast:
"I think crossovers are can be really, really
exciting. But they have to exist for a reason."
Strange New Worlds seems perfectly set
up for such an event, as it's set on the
franchise's most beloved starship and has
a cast of fan-favorite classic characters.
What could be more exciting than Jean-Luc Picard
traveling back to the days of Captain Pike or
Ethan Peck's Mr. Spock traveling to a parallel
universe and meeting Zachary Quinto's Spock?
No matter what form a crossover might take,
there's no doubt it would be a major event that
would pull in massive viewership figures.
And with Paramount and CBS now officially
merged after years of separation, there's
no longer any legal reason it can't be done.
Will that happen during Strange
New Worlds Season 2? We hope so.
Star Trek: The Original Series will be just
six years away when Season 2 of Strange New
Worlds begins, so the series may begin to
include more characters we've seen before.
It already features Spock, Uhura, Nurse
Chapel, and M'Benga, but there's still
room for plenty of old favorites. James
T. Kirk is set to play a regular role in
the second season but we don't know when
he'll take over from Christopher Pike.
Likewise, Hikaru Sulu, Pavel Chekov, and
even Yeoman Rand could have predated Kirk's
time in the captain's chair. Scotty could
be next in line to take over engineering
after the death of Lt. Hemmer, but
is it also possible that a younger
Dr. McCoy could join the sickbay staff
on his way to taking over for M'Benga?
It's not just the main cast members either. The
Star Trek franchise is full of recurring roles,
side characters, and prominent one-offs that
fans would love to see again. Gary Mitchell,
Elizabeth Dehner, Carol Marcus, and Matt Decker
could all make appearances on Strange New Worlds.
The most common adversary on the
original Star Trek and beyond,
the ruthless, war-loving Klingons
have long plagued the Federation.
But in the first season of Strange New
Worlds, the Klingons barely get a mention.
Re-introduced in Star Trek: Discovery
with a controversial new look,
it's possible that the producers simply wanted
to give the Klingons a breather. Or maybe they
needed some time to figure out what to do with
them after the divisive reaction among fans.
By the time Season 2 of Strange New Worlds rolls
around, it will have been four years since we've
seen a Klingon in live action, and it may be
time to bring them out for a new adventure.
On the Star Trek after-show The Ready
Room it's been seriously implied that
they could indeed be coming back for
the second season of Strange New Worlds.
Babs Olusanmokun who plays Dr. M'Benga
mentioned his character has a bitter
relationship with the honor-bound alien
race that will be explored next year,
so perhaps we may see them right out of the gate.
But the question remains, which Klingons we will
see? The ridged-forehead Klingons of Discovery?
Or the bronze-toned, smooth-headed
Klingons of The Original Series?
If we had to wager money, we might even
bet on seeing a new version of Kang,
Kor, or Koloth, those three Klingon warriors
who menaced Kirk in The Original Series.
Spock's betrothed T'Pring got a sizable recurring
role in Season 1 of Strange New Worlds. In the
original Star Trek episode Amok Time we learn
it was T'Pring's resentment of Spock's career
in Starfleet that was partially to
blame for ending their betrothal.
We also learn that while Spock
was serving on the Enterprise,
T'Pring was involved with a Vulcan named Stonn,
who she wished to marry. In Strange New Worlds,
we learn Stonn is a colleague of
T'Pring's at the Ankeshtan K'til Retreat,
a Vulcan criminal rehab colony on
the third moon of Omicron Lyrae.
Stonn only gets a single line
of dialogue in this appearance,
but It's still a major reveal that could
lead to a bigger role for Stonn in Season 2.
Is it possible we could see the beginnings of
his relationship with T'Pring which will cause
her to reconsider her commitment to Spock? With
Sybok possibly being set up as a major villain,
a trip back to Ankeshtan K'til and the
return of Stonn seems like it's in the cards.
If you're a longtime fan
of the Star Trek franchise,
you may have noticed a pattern
in the first season of Star Trek:
Strange New Worlds where the series did
their own versions of classic episodes.
There was the iconic "Prime Directive"
episode where the crew must decide whether
to reveal themselves to a pre-warp society.
We also saw a "disease on the ship" episode,
a "fantasy come to life" episode,
and a "monster on the ship" episode.
The season finale even did a time travel
story in classic Star Trek fashion.
But there are still plenty of classic
stories Strange New Worlds hasn't done yet.
Perhaps in Season 2 we'll see a "crew member
on trial" episode. In fact, with Number One in
custody of Starfleet Security at the close of
the cliffhanger finale, that one seems likely.
We might also see the age-old "omnipotent
being" episode, with the Enterprise encountering
an all-powerful alien life form like Q,
Trelane, or the Organians that toys with
the crew. While these tropes and time-tested
stories may be cliched and a little formulaic,
Strange New Worlds has found refreshing
ways of putting a modern spin on them.
We're looking forward to seeing what
classic tropes they could trot out next.
Episode 8 of Strange New Worlds Season
1 gave us perhaps our most puzzling and
unexpected Easter egg. In "The Elysian Kingdom" we
finally get a good look at the storybook that Dr.
M'Benga has been reading to his daughter, and
the author is none other than Benny Russell.
First appearing in a vision the Bajoran
Prophets gave Captain Benjamin Sisko
in the acclaimed Deep Space Nine
episode Far Beyond the Stars,
Russell was a fantasy author from the 1950s who
wrote stories set in the Star Trek universe.
There has always been a lingering suggestion
that perhaps there was more to Sisko's vision
than being simply a dream, but most fans had
brushed it aside as a mere fanciful thought.
Now, with Strange New Worlds declaring that Benny
Russell was a real author in-universe, we have
more questions. Was this just a throwaway gag
to amuse producers and set-dressers? Or does it
suggest that Sisko, who lived Russell's life for a
brief period, experienced something more profound?
"What if all of this is the illusion?"
We're starting to wonder the same thing ourselves.
By returning to an ensemble
format, Strange New Worlds
satisfied our wish to see the franchise
give the spotlight to its wider cast.
The first season spent time exploring Captain
Pike, Number One, and Mr. Spock's story arcs.
But there were episodes centering on
security chief La'An and Dr. M'Benga,
while major B-stories were given to Nurse Chapel
and Chief Engineer Hemmer. In fact, we arguably
learn more about Uhura in the episode Children
of the Comet than we did in all of Star Trek:
The Original Series. Sadly, one major cast member
was absent from the party: Lt. Erica Ortegas.
Captain Pike's operations officer, Ortegas
is a navigator and weapons officer,
and she was always active in any scene where the
ship saw action. Actor Melissa Navia got some fun
scenes when off-duty and offered a few cracking
one-liners, but, unfortunately, she didn't get an
episode devoted to her. Could Season 2 see the
series finally give the spotlight to Ortegas?
Fans who love her go-get-em attitude are
certainly hoping that's the case, and so are we.